welcome to this video platform of this
pre World Championship match serious
presenting games by magnus carlsen and
vigilant yeah Magnus stone here and I'm
presenting a game which is probably not
particularly well known and it's also
not particularly spectacular but it
shows some maybe though the Yap them the
biggest strength that Magnus Carlsen has
and this in my opinion it is has
strengthened simplified positions well
you really don't think that there's much
going on but at the same time however he
M somehow always manages to post some
problem see em they're set little traps
here and there and at the end somehow
the opponent some break down and this is
the typical grinding quality and says
mom this is more in tradition of players
like in cap or for even with anderson
the greater Swedish player to play in
the 70s 80s Early 90s and council really
is at his best in those endgames
simplified middle game types of
positions where there is a clear
solution that sometimes um it's based on
feel fear for the right places for all
the pieces so let's have a look at this
game it was played in 2011 in bosna
Romania the Kings tournament like is
again even choke I know I did I'm only
one she came the day before but if I'm
sure gets an evergreen player he was one
of the best players so for or he is one
of the best players last 25 years okay
we have a Queens gambit and it's the
logos and defense Bishop before a line
of the Queens gambit that has been quite
popular in recent years at some a bit of
a hybrid between the Queens gambit enter
the new Mizzou Indian like mixes ideas
it's so quite a good defense that it's a
little bit more active than the
classical Queens gambit with them there
should be seven not necessarily better
but just a bit vector okay Bishop g5
9027 this is very normal and wide
exchanges on g5 place Quincy to UM the
other main idea here simply III but
Quincy too has some particularly I'd
particular idea in mind c5 this is some
blacks counterplay he's playing against
before and now why takes on c5 this is
some the idea behind the early Quincy to
move the ideas that you can still
retreat your Bishop to d2 and not put it
on a strong and h4 i started not a bad
place but um d 2 has the idea to play
against this isolated pawn after Bishop
to age form Black has always counter
play said yes based on Queen a5 and
utilizing this pin however after Queen
d2 if like would play Queen a five you
have to reckon with a three and now with
the bishop nicely on D 2 and we will get
a position of this time it's not exactly
the new order but this type of position
will occur and this is quite nice white
castles is what you want your plate III
and
should take so we get this isolated on
position and both sides complete down
development here white plays an
interesting move Queen d3 it's not their
move that this come to you easily at
least from my from my taste in chess why
would you place the Queen in front of
the bishop it's a very direct idea
simply trying to to get the pawn and
what it does it prevents black from
playing be fine if white would pass on
here like those b5 and Bishop d7 there
for protecting this safely and also
gaining some space on the queenside with
be five black should be okay here this
move provokes night to be six and
therefore prevents the setup castles and
Bishop g4 yeah nitey force a normal
response you usually try to exchange
pieces like those if your combat the
isolated Queens pawn so 95's is logical
Bishop d7 was played like doesn't want
to trade yet he didn't need to play this
move but it's not not bad you should
have three try to increase the pressure
on t5 movie aids and now an important we
move be three this makes sure that the
c-4 square sum is controlled like a
therefore cannot play Knight see for
Bishop 83 attacking of the look and Roxy
eight nights e2
now White has regrouped this Bishop has
improved always putting a bit of
pressure here it's a very safe blockade
of deform black will never ever played
e5 before what he liked to do but how to
hard to do now and this night is not
particularly well placed it's looking
only at squares that are controlled and
in addition white might try to exchange
material on the C file so while white
has made a bit of progress it's still an
ultra solid to position for black he
exchanged on c2 made Bishop to e6 yeah
this was played because the night on b6
didn't have a good square as Bishop a5
might be an idea now on Bishop f5 you
can just simply retreat okay to bishop
see one however exchanging those are
improving the bishop yeah black and out
of the exchange there wasn't wasn't
anything better Queen d2 yeah in this
position black play an interesting play
Bishop g4 words would a move that is a
bit yeah howdy how would you call that
it's a bit of an for me in a bit of an
unconventional solution but it's a it's
not without its logic it's exchanging a
piece but at the same time the e6 Bishop
is not a particularly great piece on the
other hand you don't like to exchange so
much if you have an isolated Queens pawn
but still it seems more important to to
exchange a worst piece only six against
the better piece on f3 Carson and his
notes to the game actually gives an !
for this move so he thinks this is a
good a good exchange for like two
night at five yeah try to tickle like a
bit it's not wrestling much but why not
activate it night back to f6 and h3 this
is a bit of a passing move it's not it's
not threatening anything it's just a
little improvement and yeah like
basically also marks time tweener form
yeah okay the queen is nearing the king
here black could have taken on a to it
sir it's a play will move but it's um
it's still it's a bit risky but it's
playable between deform and I tonight
reform sorry and white will get some
attack on the king but something like
Queen a 3g form should should be
defensible considering that you have
Roxy one for example something like this
check defense for black wider does not
necessarily need to play that where he
has enough compensation for a pond but
it's not more maybe yeah aventure could
have done that but he didn't see
obviously any Nessus any necessity to do
so you just played night evade and
improves the snide tending to go to e6
here account plate night e 2 g-3
activating this night this is a tempting
move but it's not quite working 96
between age four and then g5 this is the
important point and this night is going
to get lost you can hear continue this
for bit but it's ultimately insufficient
for what
you just played this improving until 96
yeah here also there was some the idea
to play 96 which was maybe better but
still this is not not bad what Avant
should is doing guindy for threatening
night XD seven little little trick but
black just goes here the reason why
black is still ok in this position
simply because he controls the C file
it's a it's a slight prefer white but if
black has a see file he shouldn't really
lose the game ok we have the trade here
black regroups pieces too near the King
towards the center 92 and g4 important
move y term gains some space and tries
to provoke weaknesses 96 so it's ok to
trade him I'm talking to e7 no H for
King d6 ok a very long way to this
position and the way this end game now
gets lost for black I mean it's no
surprise here that I'm going to show win
for for magnesium the way this end game
gets now now gets downhill it's very
typical of many games that you place you
think okay there's not much going on and
then suddenly he's got he's got
something and if he has got something he
will win it's almost there almost a
given so um let's see what what happens
here h5 very important move
it's still not not a winning for
anything but you see now we have the
ideas are if black would take just night
f5 check and h6 is a weakness this is
the main difference in positions white
and between the positions of white and
black y term is the only from this the
only player here the only participant
you can do something meaning advancing
those pawns and try to provoke
weaknesses and detect those weaknesses
with mites especially h5 tries to fight
for the f5 square so taking as in fact
very unpleasant he played 937 covering
g6 and now very important not exchanged
looks but try to keep on the pressure I
playbook to h1 and now it's a threat to
take and take h6 so black it doesn't
have much choice he needs to take also
we could also look at this and now why
it is a good move g5 and black black is
a trouble he would get an additional
week pawn something like this it's very
unpleasant to play now you've got two
weaknesses and you've got those three
Pawn Islands against you now why this
sir is really pushing he took and play
group to g8 and now we see that f5 is a
definite weakness night g3 to f5 is the
idea and this is how it went 93
Luke g5 now before what about f4 you
might ask just retreat and this is not
leading to much if we get this kind of
continuation check here after the
capture Schneider strapped so it's not
an immediate we know anything were there
for in fact after this white should
probably go here and then it just
continues you play B form trying to get
more sophisticated about this one ideas
play a four a five and fix the weakness
on b7 you need to combine play on both
sides of the board and try to create
weaknesses plate king d 7 look edge for
introducing this idea this is also
reason why f4 was not plate 98 look at
four and nine 26 the night is not badly
placed on d6 it covers the sensitive
square it covers b5 it intense maybe 95
some some point and it protects v7 so
black really defended defended okay IM
no no question a form and now we're
unsure plate i think a debatable news we
played b6 there was no particular reason
why not just go rookie five and rook g5
just let's say mark time and wait what
white is going to do after be six white
has an additional
dear playing a five and now it's a
weakness on a six especially if you see
that the trade is pretty much false then
this is a quite obvious idea it's still
a position that black young can hold
probably but it gets it gets more tricky
now f5 and this seems to be a mistake
this point is now constantly attacked by
both nights and it wasn't it doesn't
really help like to move it probably
young still just rupee fine and do
nothing yeah now this look we regroup
and introduce this idea foi again when
now f5 this may be a pawn you can win
nights you form yeah and this sir seems
to be M the mistake the real mistake I
mean even shocked William plated seems
some not accurate moves but this seems
to lead to huge trouble um better would
have been just to drop the look back and
white white is better but it's not not
clear if you should win this probably
could have continued for for a long time
yeah white rebooting this can try to
enter here go to e5 what is better
because there are two weaknesses now to
check on also h6 but it's not clear furl
he should win not see forever has
serious drawbacks f4 look g4 and now
look H we just drop it back
a problem was if like a wide to play
something like this there's 1933 maybe
this was a line that bunch of wasps I
was planning and underestimated group 2a
three possible like now I needed to
retreat you need to need to keep the
porn what what can you do nothing else
and now the rook is getting activated
here black of course needs to hurry to
defend the Queen side yeah here's the
weakness this was created by allowing
this be six or playing b6 and allowing a
five covering the weakness check yeah
regrouping attacking instead of from 96
here also Rock b6 what the good move
activating the rook and keeping all
advantages tank but this one's was fine
the night is of course about placed on
c5 you have look be eight if like play
something like this there still will be
six note that black has really a really
big problems to keep as a material
always have to watch this this pawn this
pawn and white enters the position
change allowed this check but the
problem is you will get them get to the
airport but in the meantime ya feel for
instance look at this
it's everything here is nicely defended
so black needs to do something to even
get the porn back check can you do yup
like is regrouping this night to to get
to the a porn yeah now we r during the
decisive stage of the game and this now
is a very nicely played sir not
difficult for a player of thousand
strength but still very nicely played
you did not see through here nice
tactical move if black now takes on one
there before then not be five followed
by s haven't just promotes the pawn the
flagpoles upon an age gonna always the
biggest enemy of the night
also if Mike takes an immediate move a
seven so black just needs to draw back
no gap no more tom Jeff and here White
has a very nice nice way to win the game
it's not the only way but it's a very
direct and forcing way um he just took
on d5 this is the technical solution for
this takes pigs pigs and a 790 it's a
it's a matter of calculation black needs
to drop back the night to control the a
porn and white will grab the pawns and
this is all forced no alternatives at
all at the end this position even shook
resigned as white will promote the H
porn or the upon its a there's no way to
stop the pawns it's just a matter that
the night is a very bad piece to combat
and spawns let's say check for example
check something like this and then the
h-bond will run the only squares where
the night can stop the age porn here are
those two and he simply it simply won't
get there yeah here in age six age 7 and
and it's gone so at the end an endgame
win by Magnus note that really at the
outset of all this here
it's really looking like nothing much
and then really step by step he got
something probably not enough to win but
it's something there's this square
there's this idea and so on so black
always needs to be a bit cautious and
somehow he's managing to win those kind
of positions so often also you have this
kind of move it happens if you want a
constant pressure even if it's this
little this little pressure this
creeping pressure not the yeah the the
big sacrifices but those little moves
that somehow still keep you yeah keep
you a lot you need to be very cautious
to not give away too much in the in the
position very typical win and I think
something that we can expect in this in
this match tarsa will certainly play on
almost any end game till the end 22 also
tests on some yet it's a physical
condition and stamina um thousand is
also in excellent physical shape so he
doesn't mind to to sit there for four
four six seven hours and he's still
obviously am very much in good shape
after such a long period of playing he
still finds those those good only moves
those moves that keep the pressure on
alright thanks for watching I hope you
enjoyed this little bit of a maneuvering
game also it's not always some tactical
fireworks especially on this top level
alright thanks for watching
you